[Musique]
si vous Nicolas Gosset bonjour merci
d'être avec nous vous êtes chercheur à
l'Institut royal de de défense à
Bruxelles spécialiste de l'Asie centrale
attaché de recherche au Centre d'études
de sécurité et de défense peut-être pour
commencer une première réaction à
l'actualité à l'actualité chaude cette
deuxième prise de parole de Vladimir
Poutine tout cela en moins de 24 heures
qu'est-ce que ça vous inspire au juste
une inflation de communication à
laquelle on peut dire Vladimir Poutine
ne nous habite pas dans une mise en
scène très particulière le lieu n'est
pas anodin à la prise de vue de cette
partie la plus ancienne du Kremlin est
assez inédite elle vise à mettre en
scène un élément de pouvoir il y a
quelque chose de très grandiose dans
cette mise en scène je dirais ce qu'on
assiste en plusieurs actes et ce n'est
pas le dernier c'est l'opération
spéciale sauvetage de face et contrôle
des dégâts mise en scène de la puissance
mise en scène de tout ça n'était qu'une
petite péripétie qui n'a impacté ni le
pouvoir de Monsieur Poutine ni la
cohésion et la stabilité et la société
russe
dernier événement on entend la
rhétorique du Kremlin qui atteste que
nous que tout le contraire même mais la
question se pose malgré tout il y a une
ambivalence évidente d'une part les
figures publiques les plus connues du
système Poutine les gouverneurs de
régions sont tous salés de leur
expression de loyauté très audible ou
très visible donc de ce point de vue là
le cœur du système à serrer derrière
Vladimir Poutine ou sinon ils prigogi
n'aurait réussi et il a échoué mais
d'autre part on est confrontés à
l'évidence volte-face du président et
entre le coup de couteau dans le dos la
trahison et ensuite le cirque conduit et
se sort cette sorte de flottement dans
le traitement MAM de Wagner et de ses
hommes parce que le triple choix que
vous énonciez
initialement dans votre propos va être
tout sauf évident à mettre en oeuvre et
en plus
laisse planer des doutes quant à la
capacité réelle d'obtenir la signature
de ce fameux contrat sous le ministère
de la défense des wagnerites alors que
même ceux-ci se sont lancés dans cette
aventure sous les gilles de trilogie
pour s'opposer à ce fait donc
véritablement je pense que ce fameux
deal dont personne ne sait le contenu
entre le Kremlin et pris goji une
sous-egies de lucachenko est loin d'être
stabilisée et qu'il y a encore beaucoup
de zones qui sont probablement en
tractation au moment où nous parlons
contrat au compromis sous l'égide du
président du catchenko Président c'est
intéressant de se pencher là-dessus
aussi qu'est-ce qu'il a quel rôle a-t-il
joué ce week-end exactement ça reste là
aussi très flou on le sait proche de
Vianney Prigogine vous pensez qu'il a il
l'a convaincu d'accepter les dernières
rumeurs donnent d'ailleurs le patron de
Wagner actuellement en Biélorussie à
Minsk son avion son avion privé aurait
atterri le travail il y a quelques
heures maintenant oui effectivement il y
a un groupe un avion du groupe Concorde
qui a été tracé ça a été confirmé
écoutez sur le rôle de lucaschenko je
suis assez en phase avec ce que
l'excellent journaliste Benoît Vicky n'a
déclaré le journaliste du Monde qui dit
en fait il est il est forte à penser que
le cacher une coiffe fait davantage au
fils de garant à cette cette tractation
entre le Kremlin et et prix gauche une
parce que lorsque l'on évoque comme l'a
fait pièce coffre le porte-parole du
Kremlin la longue connaissance qu'il
datait de plus de 25 ans c'était
d'ailleurs intéressant entre le cash and
Co et trigogine on pourrait rétorquer
que Poutine le connaît encore depuis
bien plus longtemps donc il est forte à
penser que lucasienco a fait office de
voix de sortie de garantie d'une voie de
sortie pour trilogie mais sans que
celui-ci ne puisse en obtenir quelque
chose de très concret par rapport à son
futur personnel et au futur du groupe il
faut bien se dire aussi que nous cacher
un corps est inventé à des problèmes de
stabilité de son propre régime en
Biélorussie et que avoir quelques
milliers d'hommes de Wagner relabilisés
possiblement sous un autre format serait
quelque chose de naturel à l'aider il a
gagné en influence avec avec ce coup de
force manqué en tout cas publiquement le
cacher une coiffe et office de a fait la
preuve de son bon office auprès du
Kremlin alors que jusqu'à présent on
était habitué à ce qu'il soit plutôt une
figure de de second plan aux ordres et
soumis aux bonnes volonté du Kremlin
donc de ce point de vue là il s'est
réaffermi dans le jeu duettiste par
rapport à Poutine un mot peut-être
devenu prigogi puisque Vladimir Poutine
il y a quelques instants estimait que ni
l'armée ni la population avait soutenu
la rébellion de Wagner c'est à peu près
tout l'inverse que de ce cas sûr et de
ce qu'affirme Eugénie Prigogine est-ce
que vous vous estimez qu'il a il s'est
renforcé dans l'opinion publique russe
lui qui apparemment se trouverait donc
maintenant en Biélorussie mais dont on
connaît aussi les ambitions politiques
c'est très difficile à dire on voit
d'une part que Poutine continue de le
prendre très au sérieux ne le citant pas
on voit aussi que privilégiène dans sa
bref allocution audio continue dans une
forme de défiance puisqu'il dit
finalement nous avons démontré la
faiblesse de la sécurité de la Russie
dans une sorte de coup d'éclat donc il
est visiblement pas complètement rentré
dans le rang et le flottement sur son
sort personnel reste quelque chose que
Poutine manoeuvre avec difficulté
puisqu'on ne le cite pas il y a une
volonté de ne pas le négliger en martyrs
de ne pas gonfler davantage l'aura qu'il
peut avoir dans certaines parties de la
société russe quant à ce que vous
évoquiez les signes de d'encouragement
de la population de rostovnado nous ils
sont difficiles à interpréter est-ce que
c'était vraiment de l'engouement pour
privilégier les wagnermans ou des
applaudissements à la satisfaction de
voir toute cette mauvaises situations
s'arrêter une histoire de stabilité
revenir en tout cas il y a eu une
crainte au Kremlin dans l'élite que la
base de soutien et le capital politique
de prix gaugine soit beaucoup plus
importante que ce qu'ils estimaient à la
base et ce qui semble justifier la la
prudence du traitement vis-à-vis de
l'ancien ou toujours en fort de Wagner
dans les heures qui sont en train de se
dérouler Nicolas Gosset avec nous on va
s'intéresser maintenant on y reviendra
avec vous dans quelques minutes à ce qui
se passe sur le terrain ukrainien les
Ukrainiens déterminés à profiter de la
situation volonymer Zelinski s'est rendu
ces dernières heures sur le front est un
déplacement dont les images non cessé de
tourner en boucle hier à la télévision
ukrainienne qui est annonçant dans les
secteurs de deniers ce qui et Berdiansk
et désavancées la libération aussi de
villages dans la région de zapporelgia
le point tout de suite en images avec
Florent Renaud
c'est une plongée au cœur de la bataille
sur ces images diffusées par les garde
de frontières Ukrainiens les combats
toujours en cours pour la conquête de
barmouth ville où les mercenaires de
Wagner étaient les plus aguerris
la mitrailleuse en transaction mais le
danger lui est déjà ailleurs
caché en sous-sol cette officier
prévient ses frères d'armes un soldat
russe est en train de percer leur ligne
sa position est bombardée quelques
secondes plus tard
un exemple parmi tant d'autres de la
difficulté actuelle des Russes sur le
terrain
qui a fait formel depuis la rébellion
avortée du groupe Wagner et même si
volodime Hélène ski reconnaît que la
progression est plus lente que prévu ces
hommes reprennent des positions aux
Russes qui eux enchaînent les revers
ainsi que les troupes d'occupation
russes subissent des pertes importantes
en personnel en armes et en équipement
les soldats ukrainiens ont mené des
opérations offensives dans la direction
de darkmouth dans les zones des colonies
Dory rive vassiliveca
ivanivsquée courte du Mika et
pivenichenet et ils ont réussi à prendre
pied dans ses territoires des pertes
significatives selon les Ukrainiens il
l'assure rien que lundi près de barmut
153 soldats russes sont morts et pas
moins de 200 autres ont été blessés
voilà Nicolas Gosset je me tourne vers
vous voilà pour ce qui s'est passé
parallèlement évidemment assez assez
diverses prises de paroles en territoire
ukrainien volo du mirzelinski lui qui en
a profité pour accompagner de caméra se
rendre se rendre sur le terrain ça peut
être quoi justement l'impact de ces
événements sur le conflit en Ukraine
aujourd'hui
alors écoutez il y a une sorte de
déconnexion entre la progression des
opérations et la situation politique
interne en Russie si d'abord et avant
tout des soldats russes n'ont pas été
appelés du front ukrainien pour venir
soutenir l'opération dite antiterroriste
contre la montée du convoi de Wagner
c'est parce que l'essentiel de la Force
opérationnelle terrestre de la
Fédération de Russie est engagée en
Ukraine au-delà de 90% et donc ils n'ont
pas voulu dégarnir le front ukrainien
pour ne pas prendre le risque de
favoriser une éventuelle percée
ukrainienne ce qui traduisait aussi le
fait que dans les hautes sphères à
Moscou au Kremlin il y avait aucune
certitude sur la durée de toute cette
aventure Prigogine au pays ça c'est la
première chose deuxième chose
l'événement a été de trop courte durée
que pour impacter durablement le champ
des opérations on en est toujours à
cette phase où les Ukrainiens n'ont pas
engagé leur réserve je pense qu'ils ont
eu l'extrême prudence de ne pas tirer de
conclusion trop hâtive et d'envoyer
davantage de brigades au front courant
le risque que ça ne soit pas le moment
de l'opportunité et c'était
effectivement le cas alors on est
toujours dans cette phase de
contre-offensive mais qui reste limité
dans sa montée en puissance on a
seulement quatre brigades nouvellement
formés qui sont engagés avec des progrès
qu'on peut simplement décrire comme un
grignotage qui se poursuit alors
effectivement les Ukrainiens annoncent
la village là un autre quelques
kilomètres mais ça reste très très
parcellaire et très lent pour le moment
avec deux développements potentiels qui
sont à suivre dans les jours et dans les
semaines qui viennent
l'annonce d'une tête de pont qui a été
établie sur le Nièvre dans la zone de
kerzone qui tente à montrer que
l'anesthésie du terrain dans cette zone
qui a été causée par l'effondrement du
barrage de No est terminé et que les
Ukrainiens considèrent qu'ils peuvent
repasser à l'action dans cette zone et
ensuite toujours sujet à confirmation
mais en fonction de l'information dont
je dispose ça semble être le cas il
serait parvenu à franchir la rivière ces
Verdun dans l'Est dans la zone de les
situations qui servait redonné ce qui
permettrait de passer de l'autre côté de
l'obla de l'ouransk et donc d'avoir des
développements beaucoup plus importants
dans cette zone que ce que nous avons
connu jusqu'à présent donc pour résumer
en instant où nous nous parlons aucune
modification drastique de la situation
sur le terrain causé par les événements
en Russie mais un effet d'entraînement
de la contre-offensive ukrainienne qui
continue à monter en puissance et qui
semble maintenant prêt à engager des
gains en termes de franchissement des
premières lignes de défense russe qui
permettront de monter en puissance dans
les semaines qui viennent merci beaucoup
Nicolas dossier vous étiez notre notre
invité du jour